Hey Kip, how you doing?
Hey, Team, I'm good. How are you?
All right, and that's what my team's here. I get my video working here.
Okay.
But how things been going for you?
Good, good, and how about you?
Oh, same, same. Never A dull moment here, but you know.
And it's OK.
Anything planned for this weekend?
No, no, not really. Yu.
We have some training, leadership training this weekend. So yeah, so we'll be there.
Ah.
And for these two days, we will get a comp off that we can take on some other day.
Make it up somewhere else, huh?
Yeah, but it's good to learn new things. So yeah, I'm excited.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, how are things moving in Mohit?
Oh, so far, so good. I mean, we're giving a lot of email migration projects, and so he's been pretty decent with that so far.
They got about to wrap up a couple of them, so...
Things are going, going great from my point of view, anyway.
Anything you would like to share, any feedback on that Bear, you think he needs to improve?
Hmm.
I don't know, it kind of goes to say for everybody, but...
Not anything specific I can mention. I mean...
The fact that nothing comes to mind is a good thing.
Okay.
I know he was going to be taking that Microsoft exam. I don't know if he's already taken that exam yet or that's still in his schedule to do so.
Kip.
Yeah, it's still in his schedule. He has not done that exam, so he will most likely do it by the end of this month. Yeah.
Hoh.
Yeah, he's almost ready, so just need to go through the exam.
At.
Yeah.
I got one coming up myself. That's why i'm like Oh, shoot, you know. But
I think.
Okay, so I guess we can share my screen and then we can go through his performance for the last three weeks.
Let me know once you're able to see my screen.
Yep.
Okay, great. So once again, welcome to our monthly business review and this is from March 22nd till April 11th.
And agenda would be the same: check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap.
Started with the check-in. We already talked about how things are moving, and we got a good feedback from Keith. Thank you, and we really appreciate your help and support.
In the highlights, we have been getting positive feedback from Mohit and we also, you also confirmed the end user CSAT was positive as well. So how the end user CSAT looks like for these, for the last three weeks?
Okay.
Did we get any end user feedbacks from Mohit?
Kip.
Um, no, no, we have not.
Okay.
Okay, and we already talked about he's been working on Office 365 email migration projects a lot and also working on drive space and the backup optimization.
Yeah, looking whatever.
This is a...
Okay.
And we also talked about the KPI setup and we considered use of Team GPS for tracking the performance.
So have we made any progress?
Okay.
Unfortunately, no, I have not made any progress with that part yet. We are still in progress with that. I have some KPIs listed and things of that nature, but I don't have anything automated just yet.
Mhm.
Okay, do let us know in case you need any help. So.
Which is most likely going to be the case eventually here.
Once I have that lined up, I can reach out because I know, at least with Vikram and Ryan, I can talk to you. I know we've talked to them in the past as well, so.
Mhm.
I understand. Okay.
And CSAT survey from Mohit for the month of March was sent. So keep an eye on your inbox. And so, yeah, do take out some time to fill that out.
Okay.
Kour.
And moving on to the action tracker, we already talked about the KPI setup that's still in progress. And we also discussed on the training and certification on MD102 for Mohit. We expect him to complete this.
Mhm.
the end of this month.
Hey, Chan.
He may have just joined her.
Hello there, sorry, I had an issue with Teams. I couldn't get connected, but until I had to restart all my devices and now I'm connected. But I don't know what I missed, but probably no need to recap because it looks like Tim was on. I can just say I have no concerns, no issues, so I don't really have any feedback to provide.
Okay.
Thank you, Chan. Yeah.
Had to jump on my phone 1st and then try to reboot my computer and then see if that helped. And okay, now I'm finally in, but more things to figure out once I'm done here.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So these are the KPIs we discussed. And let's jump into the performance. Pomalkeep, his utilization for the last three weeks had been pretty consistent, around 80%. So it's been pretty stable.
Okay.
He worked on the projects and on the support tickets as well.
Any any questions on this?
No, not yet. I think it's just we keep them in a loop with things that we're doing here internally.
And.
Mmhm.
And so if we got more information on that, I'll send it along here. We're going to get him involved in a few more things for Huntress and things of that nature to kind of do some remediation on that. But I'll keep you in the loop with everything with that as well.
Mhm.
Absolutely, thank you. I would really appreciate that. And this is his ticket closure. So he closed 85 tickets in three weeks. That makes an average of 28 tickets per week. On week one and week three, the ticket closures were pretty less. I believe that was mostly due to the project work.
Email migrations and.
Mhm.
Any questions on this?
No, not yet.
Okay.
And way forward, he's still focused on converting recurring issues into the permanent fixes via automation, SOP thresholds, and also the KPI set up that we discuss. So yeah.
AI by design, that's already discussed with you.
Mhm.
And this is the Team GPS. You already know in case you...
Face any issues, queries, do let us know. We will engage the appropriate team to look into that.
OK.
And that's it.
Perfect.
Anything additional you want to share?
Just, you know, the ever-changing world here. We'll keep you in the loop with everything that's kind of going on here as far as internal changes. If we, hey, we got this project going on, we have this kind of, we're toying with some products here to help with some of our...
Mm.
No.
remediation would help desk and things of that nature. So it's something to kind of keep him in the loop with to say, hey, this is kind of something we're doing here. So as soon as we get more information on that, we'll let you know. And if he has any feedback for us, you know, definitely.
Let us know.
Definitely, definitely, yeah.
Right.
All right, so I guess that's all we have for today. Keep a check on the CSAT survey from Mohit for the month of March. And I guess that's it from my side. So thank you for joining this call today, and happy Friday and happy weekend.
Okay.
All right, same to you, Kip. All right, we'll see you again. Thanks. Yep. Bye.
Yeah. Thank you, Chad. Thank you, Tim. Bye.